400 pound NYPD robot gets tryout in
Times Square subway station the K-5
described as fully autonomous security
robot as part of a push by the mayor for
more law enforcement technology with
which is yeah I mean this folks just you
know if we're gonna have if you're gonna
put bring more and more people in get
ready for the bot and the security robot
and by the way I just try to get on the
good side of these things they're not
going away they're not going away you
couldn't scream and yell about the
autonomous bot that will now Patrol the
subway your only job if you live in New
York is to get on the good side of the
bot because that's not going away that
there's no look how happy that cop is
standing next to that bot look how
thrilled he is that they can blame
someone else besides him they will that
bot will start pushing people onto the
subway tracks and look how thrilled the
cut they're all happy with the but this
is all they've wanted since the George
Floyd stuff they just go just bring into
machines please please someone else to
blame bring in the Bots bringing the
autonomous bringing the K5 whatever they
call it they're thrilled if if you're a
cop in this city this is your partner
now this is who you blame everything on
oh my God you're gonna be like no no
this is the K5 okay this is the K5
there's not going to be uh a situation
by the way where this will not be used
they are going to use this for
everything it's starting in the subway
but then it'll be on the street it's
gonna be on the street it's you're just
gonna see it it's gonna go it's gonna go
by it's gonna turn around and look at
you it's gonna do like a sensor thing
and then it's going to decide what it's
going to do
so try to get on the good side of the K5
bot if you can
um because
you know Mark radlin a restaurant
manager says it looks like an oversized
version of R2D2 a Droid from the Star
Wars films I don't know what it's
supposed to be
I don't know what it's supposed to be it
looks like a trash can on Wheels stop
insulting it this is stop on it
I'm telling you stop
it's from a california-based maker night
scope woo
night scope describes it as a quote
fully autonomous outdoor security robot
a fully autonomous outdoor security
robot it's currently used in hospitals
malls airports warehouses and casinos
and it will soon be deployed to Times
Square subway station the city's busiest
underground Transit Hub it's armed with
four cameras it will record video but
not audio it will employ facial
recognition at uh you know so they're
just gonna they're gonna be able to
identify you immediately
and it's about the cost of leasing it
averages out to about nine dollars per
hour nice and cheap
our mayor the good Eric Adams says this
is below minimum wage no bathroom breaks
no meal breaks
they're all in on the bot they're all in
on it they are thrilled they're good
because cops are quitting now cops gotta
want to do this or you know some
cities are are are allocating some of
the police budget somewhere else and now
we have the fully autonomous bot
who can do facial recognition on you
I see the bot can't
the butts this is the first step the
first stage of the bot
the bot can't restrain you yet
the bot can't do anything to you yet
this is the first bot the bot will only
get better and night scope don't think
Knight scope didn't have that
conversation don't think knightscope
didn't go by the way this is only the
demo this is only our first bot we have
bots in production that can do things
you know all the cops and Eric Adams are
sitting in a in a conference room and
night scope whatever the hell that is
based in California night scope has a
video monitor on the wall and it's just
Transformer style Bots pinning people to
the wall and chucking them and
I'm telling you the cops are ear to ear
Smiles Eric Adams is like and how much
will these guys do this for they're like
it's nine an hour we can maybe get it
down to six maybe the Bots that attack
people will be 15. maybe the Bots that
have the full capacity to restrain
people that might be 15. but they're all
sitting there they're all very excited
because they know this is just the
beginning they know it's just the
beginning and don't think it's uh by the
way it's any type of coincidence that we
have this migrant crisis and now we have
the Bots coming in because all you
people need to accept the bot and the
only way they're going to accept the bot
is if they're going to their house and
they see all of these people lurking in
the streets and now they're going to be
intense they're desperate we've thrown
them out of the hotels they don't know
what to do they're desperate they're
hungry they can't get any services from
the government what are they going to do
they're going to go well that lady's got
a pocketbook that guy might have a
wallet and things could get dicey and
that's when they start going and here
are the Bots here are the Bots and uh
yeah I just wish I could have been a fly
on the wall
for the meeting when they went into the
NYPD and they said meet your new partner
K-5
and those guys are like yeah but what
could K5 really do he's got facial
recognition you know and they go yeah
this is the first generation they go you
know iPhones right in the cops look yeah
I know iPhones you know how when the
first one came out it couldn't do much
didn't really have a great camera you
know you couldn't do much and then every
generation of the phone got better and
better and better and more capable and
now you can't live without your phone if
you don't have your phone even for
several minutes you freaked the out
that's what we're gonna do with the bot
every generation of the K5 what do you
think the k7's gonna do it's the K5 can
identify you on the street and can use
facial recognition to know who you are
what do you think the K7 what about the
K-9 the K9 should be one that looks like
a dog for fun
what do you think the canines gonna do
the K10
I mean if you all live long enough
you'll live long enough to see the k-15
now the k-15s job is to basically sense
you're gonna commit a crime before you
commit it and then get you down and then
deactivate you on the street before
you're able to do anything
it's it's uh terrifying but you gotta
embrace it so get on the good side
because it's not going away get on the
good side of the K5 however you're gonna
do it pet it rub it when you walk in go
hello okay like just start being
obedient
to the fully autonomous security bot in
the subway start being obedient and
maybe he'll record because he's going to
record everything by the way then we're
gonna record your reactions they have
facial recognition they know exactly who
you are so if you're like one of these
people that's like you K5 the KA is
gonna remit they're gonna pull the file
up as soon as they see you when they're
gonna go oh that guy wasn't really nice
to K5 he was kind of a he called K5
a you spit on K5 that wasn't
really nice I think this guy's a problem
I think this guy needs a little attitude
adjustment he was very nasty him and his
friends actually kicked K5 for no
goddamn reason I'm K8 poor K5 didn't
know how to handle these guys I know K8
knows exactly what to do so whatever you
do around these Bots just know it will
be recorded for future use it will
absolutely be recorded it's going into a
database any anti-social behavior that
you display around K5 is going to be
remembered by K9 K10 and k11 they're
going to be able to pull it up and go
you know what
you weren't really a team player when we
rolled out our little brother K5 were
you no we actually pulled up your file
and we just watched some of your
behavior and you know what we're not
excited no follow you home they're gonna
follow you home they'll follow you home
it's it this is all happening this is
all happening you may not like it but
it's all gonna happen so my advice to
you while you can get in good with K5 if
I ever see K5 I'm going to just be like
hello K5 thank you for coming to our
city I love you K5 look at K5 and go I
love you K5 because that's gonna get
saved they're going to record everything
that you do and they're go and all the
generations of the security Bots will
remember it if they're gonna remember it
so just know that Mr Adams who once
patrolled the Subways as a Transit cop
was elected on a promise to reduce crime
without violating New Yorkers civil
rights he supports using technology to
enhance law enforcement the mayor
returned in August from a trip to Israel
always good news where he saw how law
enforcement there uses drones in
conjunction with motorcycle and I love
by the way that we go to Israel Israel
and Palestine have been fighting forever
and ever they have a very tense security
situation and it should not be the model
for our country our country should not
we should not model anything after the
Gaza Strip there's no way that we should
model policing in Columbus Ohio after
the most volatile region in the world so
whenever anybody gets back from a trip
to Israel the most volatile region in
the world and they were there to talk
about security that's no good that's not
good they come back and they're like
well I mean listen you take El Al the
airline and it is you it is the most
secure you ever feel flying because they
do these crazy and it's understandable
because they've lived with this threat
of political instability and terrorism
for a very very long time right not
notwithstanding their their role in that
I'm not going into that right now what
I'm saying is that modeling our security
situation after the most volatile place
in the world is only going to get
everybody's civil rights snatched away
Mr Adams is also a promoted proponent of
digidog a robotic dog that is deployed
in emergency situations such as building
collapses
there's nothing better in a building
collapse than a robotic dog
we've all seen digidog there's digidog
right there so Digi dog
by the way notice how all this stuff
they're all lying all the time they're
like uh Digi dog is for the building
collapse
what does anyone believe that does
anyone believe the only time you're
gonna see digidog is in the
once every 10-year building Club how
many buildings are collapsing in the
city that you need an army of digital
dogs but this is the way the Press is
writing it up they're like no digidog's
here for the tsunami
and the building collapses and uh if
there's uh you know the earthquakes at
New York City uh experiences once every
400 years that's that's why we have
digidog no no no we have a fully
autonomous robot dog
for the building collapse so that if
you're in the rubble
of a building that has just collapsed
and you are comforted by this uh Digi
dog
so it's not going to do anything else
so digidog's not gonna do it you smoke a
weed on a park bench digidog's not gonna
show up out of nowhere
digidog's not gonna show up
is that is that what we believe there's
gonna be no Digi dog in other situations
I think there might be I think digidog
might find his way out of the building
collapse and into your life but notice
how this is all brought out it's all
brought out in a very positive helpful
let's see we're saving money we're
saving money and there's building
collapses and don't you want to get
saved by a digital dog watch this
article New York City officials unveiled
three new high policing devices Tuesday
including a robotic dog that critics
called creepy
when it was first debuted two and a half
years ago the new devices which also
include a GPS tracker for stolen cars
and a cone-shaped security robot will be
rolled out in a manner that is
transparent consistent and always done
in close collaboration with the people
we serve
did your dog is out of the pound said
Eric Adams a Democrat thank God our man
this is what happens when the mayor's on
coke and you could just hand the mayor
an eight ball and go sit down we got a
lot of cool stuff we're about to show
you he's sitting there he's like
did your dog is now part of the
tool kit that we are using by the way is
there any is there anything worse than
that by the way all you need is to not
let criminals out of jail you need bail
laws that actually makes sense you need
areas to be adequately policed you need
cops to be uh adequately trained we've
all decided we can't do any of that
we've all decided we can't do any of
that bring on K5 and digidog by the way
because we've decided we can't do it we
can't train police we can't tell them to
just not shoot innocent black people in
the face we can't figure out a way to
give criminals the appropriate amount of
bails none of this can be done it it
can't be done we've given up it's not
gonna work human beings have failed it's
not going to happen what's going to
happen is we're gonna bring on robots
and digital dogs and that's gonna be the
way we're gonna do it